play against mr jules another 2300
player i thought it might be julian okay
knight f6 c4 see if he wants to play
grunfeld or
budapest again
all right this time we'll play e4 which
is something that shankland recommends i
think
e4f4 here i think i'm supposed to do
here maybe it's bishop e3 i don't
remember
it's kind of a very interesting
very interesting line
right now we have two bishops pretty
good position
knight f3
all right so
we gave up the bishop pair but in return
we doubled his pawns and we have a
strong center
which he has to kind of worry about
because i could develop
a pretty strong attack here oh he even
goes g6 that one is very dangerous i
think he should have played h6
i thought because now i go knight of six
and uh
yeah i think uh giving up that square
seems very dangerous for him
i wonder if i can even try to mate him
somehow on the h6 square
can i even play a 5 here let's see a 5
95 f e
yeah i think a 5 is
quite good
yeah 3 plus 2 is good yes three plus two
is good queen h
h6
yeah i think this is game over
made in a few moves or i mean he can
take enough six but
still yeah so i think uh
the whole position wasn't great but i
think knight g5 h6 at least should have
been uh tried because
g6 was too dangerous